this is a golden Mantella  they are critically endangered and only  found in a mere four square miles in  part of east central madagascar at only  one inch long this little one is  actually fully grown for what they may  lack in size they make up for in color  they're mildly toxic skin is bright  yellow orange and sometimes red golden  mint Ella's are insectivores feeding on  termites fruit flies and a range of  other insects although they have very  few predators in the wild they've been  over collected for the pet trade they  are endemic to swamps with elevations  close to 3,000 feet but rapid  deforestation of a unique habitat has  left them critically endangered this is  a golden Mantella  [Music]